jean-claude picard nous a donné rendez
vous sur l'un de ses sites ligériens de
prédilection dont il garde jalousement
le secret une habitude héritée de son
ancienne pratique de la pêche à la
mouche
il ya beaucoup de cailloux et le caillou
apporter nourriture ça c'est vraiment
primordial sont les des zones de
reposoir et puis ce portage certains
espèces alors thouars également
jean-claude picard s'adonnent à la
photographie depuis près de dix ans à la
lumière de l'aube et des couchers de
soleil un hobby sur le tard devenu
passion qu'il vit à bord de ces afflux
flottant où il goûte de façon
inconditionnelle au plaisir de la proche
l'approché quelque chose d'un petit peu
passionnel lorsque j'arrive au bord de
l'eau j'ai mon temps à fut pour moi
c'est toujours comme la première fois
donc je pénètre dans l'eau et là c'est
vraiment un grand plaisir
il faut pas aller directement sur le
sujet donc on l'a proche d'une façon
extrêmement par la douceur quoi parlera
pas de bruit pas pas de gestes
intempestifs a pas de remous au fil des
50 km du fleuve qu'il arpente
jean-claude picard est devenu un grand
connaisseur de l'afo nigérienne une
sorte de sentinelle de l'environnement
là certains sites où malheureusement je
ne trouve pas la faune que je pouvais
espérer il ya dix ans par exemple
certaines zones de migration je n'en
vois plus la raison je la connais pas
mais
le certains migrateurs qui étaient
présents en avril on voit les passagers
migration je vois beaucoup moins ou pas
du tout sujet sur certains postes
ces photos multi primé par le public ont
été exposés au prestigieux festival
nature de namur en belgique
elles sont à voir à la maison de loire
de jargeau jusqu'au 1er septembre